il coraggio complicato trovare
manzoni diceva
ci fa dire a uno dei suoi personaggi che
è impossibile darcelo il coraggio in
qualcosa che hai
oppure oppure non hai
non sono fino in fondo convinto di
questa cosa che fa dire a don abbondio
manzoni in realtà sono convinto che il
coraggio sia
qualcosa in più che un temerario età
spingersi a fare qualcosa non temendo le
conseguenze
il coraggio invece possa essere una cosa
che prendi
formi e costruisci attraverso la
conoscenza e anche cercando di resistere
ai pregiudizi
la cosa più complicata in questo momento
per chi europeo per chi vive in europa
per i popoli del mediterraneo
è quello di vedere una politica
internazionale sempre più parla un
linguaggio e fate le scelte che
risultano spesso molto lontane dalla
vita quotidiana
e coraggio significa affrontare gli
albanesi hanno dimostrato più volte di
avere coraggio nella loro storia dalla
resistenza e nazisti alla resistenza al
comunismo
la resistenza quest'ultima anche poco
raccontata rispetto a quello che è
venuto fuori da sovietica ma anche dalla
dalla romania parlo come pubblicazioni
qui ci sono ci sono molte le attuali
dissidenti di grande valore che hanno
spesso avuto una eco minore
questo coraggio quindi di resistenza
questo coraggio di resistenza io lo
sento molto diverso per esempio nota
dall altro popolo italiano meridionale
che ha visto solo una delle due grandi
tirannie d'europa e che quindi spesso a
difetta di imprudenza anche nei
linguaggi e il modo di esprimersi della
politica a volte utilizzo della politica
italiana
delle frasi o delle posizioni populiste
che magari appunto un popolo come quello
paese direbbe immediatamente e che il
coraggio qui
e lo stesso coraggio sia in nel sud
italia e cioè
di non credere e raccontare delle
proprie contraddizioni
c'è un modo per delegittimare la propria
cultura la propria identità alla propria
storia
chi racconta la e le proprie ferite
quello che non funziona lo sta
insultando se stesso è capitato in
queste ore è di chiedere di fare domande
c'era un po come quella resistenza che
nella mia città trovo molte volte la
prima scusa perché mi hai chiesto questa
cosa qui va tutto bene è una specie di
protezione
non è per forza connivenza omertà poi lo
può diventare ma c'è innanzitutto paura
ora di essere fraintesi paura di essere
ridotti ridimensionati paura che ci sia
semplicemente una sintesi negativa
ombrosa
possa di colpo togliere tutta la
bellezza la luminosità l'altro che c'è
in una terra era una cultura questa è
una paura legittima ma il coraggio non è
negare la contraddizione nasconderla far
finta che queste ferite non esiste
affrontarla affrontarla significa a
raccontarlo
e a compare significa poter descrivere
come vanno le cose
e io sono convinto che gli sforzi sono
molti ci sento che c'è un riscatto una
possibilità
il lavoro di realizzare molto
interessante che non è facile trovare un
editore d'europa per niente
detto questo bisogna guardare in faccia
le cose che non vanno
la complessità del sistema giudiziario
la corruzione dei giudici
l'infinito flusso di riciclaggio la
presenza costante importante delle
organizzazioni criminali non sono cose
contro l'albania raccontare raccontare
queste cose non significa andare contro
l'albania e fare queste cose significa
essere contro l'albania quindi in
qualche modo il coraggio e ci dobbiamo
dare il coraggio di guardare queste cose
che non esistono cause difficili da
vincere ci sono solo cause costose però
quello che io incontro in albania e la
speranza l'energia paese giovane
giovanissimo una delle cose più
interessanti del dibattito che vedo sui
social network che
in genere i ragazzi albesi non sono
abituati a sentire parlare bene della
propria terra
quindi quando c'è un elogio un
riferimento più romantico ingenuo quindi
c'è immediatamente una parte che ne
viene nutrita il lettore è felice lo
stesso lettore ho notato che poi critica
ovviamente questo mi piace che mi piace
che il fatto di sentirsi fieri di
appartenere una cultura una terra non
condiziona poi il giudizio anche se è
vero sulle cose che non vanno
ma cosa molto bella entrambi siamo paesi
popoli di migranti e noi
a noi tocca a noi italiani a noi
albanesi a noi albanesi dicevo a noi
tocca a dover raccontare cosa significa
essere migrante in europa tocca a noi o
che noi più che ad altri per questo
chiudo con un altro verso la positiva
una poetessa un altro mio grande amore
spiega spesso uscita si chiama wee small
hours xin mosca difficile da pronunciare
ma molto facile da leggere in mezzo
cito questo verso per chiudere
semplicemente perché credo che questo
verso è scrive più di qualsiasi
ragionamento razionale e l'empatia
ascolta
come mi batte forte il tuo cuore verso
semplice credo che queste parole c'è
tutto il coraggio possibile per cambiare
cioè ascoltare il proprio cuore come
quella altrui
grazie